[Music]
I got a damn key audio editor slash
Foley artist I guess 37 seconds of
silence was to me up with his sudden
pterodactyl noise and if so Bravo in a
world where Bravo means go yourself
um the moon is nowhere near that size
relative to the earth but whatever you
say is suppose it's serious space movie
[Music]
hard to believe any alien life will
contact us after hearing this jumbled
mass of frequencies oh you're the race
that came up with we built this city
here's the keys to interstellar travel
wow the further out from Earth you go
the more nebula you encounter and in
such tight consecutive formation two
entirely too much space travel I have
often thought the entire universe
somehow existed in jena malone said one
of the most infuriating meaningless
movie things ever is her dad moving
behind her to fully close the door why
was the door ajar why would Ellie a
presumably smart girl even begin audio
recording without checking all the exits
but if it's so unimportant to her
broadcast why bother showing the dead
walking behind to close it I mean god
damn what gives she has a pretty precise
threat of contacts with her radio all
around the Midwest but somehow her
farthest one yet goes all the way down
to Florida baby steps radio maybe
Kentucky first before Florida young
Ellie's genuine radio curiosity nearly
turned this space program think piece
into frequency the little girl edition
guys I'm getting a weird feeling that
one of Sean beans characters has died
here before Matthew McConaughey shows up
and somehow takes away from this movie
paw and jaws Palmer shakes Ellie's hand
with sticky Cracker Jack fingers red
Jeep pulling it hot damn are all the
vehicles in this lot red jeeps what is
this jurassic park got my master's in
divinity then i dropped out of seminary
and went off into some secular
humanitarian work wait you got a
master's in divinity and then dropped
out of school isn't that like quitting
the american ninja warrior contest after
beating the course I mean are you a
Superman of God or not this movie kinda
needs you to pick a side
young Ellie watches the spaceship with
her dad well next-door house arrest Shia
LaBeouf is looking at them through
binoculars and assessing their murderous
nacelle would be literally no
so civilizations out there well if there
wasn't being awful waste of space huh
that's exactly what her dad said to her
when she was little well on also you
died when I was 9 years old I never got
to know my mother then who took care of
you after that I don't think we hear of
an uncle or cousin or anybody who then
raised young Elli during her formative
years so that she could keep on this
radio for alien life track she set for
herself at such a young age I'll get the
medicine thankfully for this movie's
tension meter this asshole collapsed on
the first floor while his dad medicine
is up on the second floor I won't make
fun of her nine-year-old running ability
here because it's hilarious but then she
opens the medicine cabinet revealing
this is a Gloria shot where I can't see
the camera even though I should be able
to and ultimately I'm just gonna take a
sin off it camera pan from multiple
prescription bottles to the
father-daughter photo is manipulative as
hell dog yo Zemeckis you are better than
this she's currently worried about how a
nine-year-old will be able to keep
paying the bills and maintain this house
without working five illegal jobs hey
maybe if you hadn't been so space
oriented your dad would still be alive
sometimes we just have to accept it as
God's will wow this priest knew exactly
what a nine-year-old needed to hear to
completely get over her dad's sudden
death that's amazing dad are you there
you just buried him girl give his spirit
time to adapt to the either Jesus we
could put together a kick-ass ad hoc
SETI program somehow even though
drumlins pulled the plug on Ellie's
research she was allowed to continue to
do this research without being informed
but they did tell Kent he decides the
best way to break this news is to stall
with hey we can do this somewhere else
with no money don't worry about why I'm
telling you this just get on board with
the dammit you won't be taken seriously
and your career will be over before it's
begun so what it's my life oh I did not
know this movie was gonna turn into
rebel without a cause sure maybe she
decides not to call this guy okay
whatever why does she leave this note
here on the nightstand next to a bed she
doesn't plan to revisit ever you're
leaving throw that person away or else
take it with you right mm I wonder if
Ellie is going to be successful asking
for money here the guy who runs this
company had an alien burst out of his
chest 18 years ago probably not the best
place to start proposal seems less like
science and more like science fiction
nice line but you could have deduced
that from her pitch package and kept her
from ever entering the building and
giving this pitch which suggests you
either think she's right or else she
just want to go out of your way to
embarrass her here's something really
nutty I heard of a couple guys that want
to build something called an airplane
great at least playing with someone once
built an airplane and everyone thought
they were crazy card it's like every
terrible band out there who point the
Rolling Stones reviews of Led Zeppelin
albums and say
see they got it wrong then who's to say
they are wrong now it is literally never
a good sign when the movie gives you a
four years later title car this has got
to be the least stressful job on the
planet until 2012 when two assholes made
a YouTube channel and started taking
potshots at movies I have to go it alone
on going along got it before and now if
you'll excuse me I'm gonna go be angsty
at a discount grand canyon gorge which
is conveniently super nearby Ellie's
wondering how in the world a nine year
old was able to pay the bills and
maintain a house without working five
illegal jobs just in time to save
Ellie's second chance at finding alien
life this computer is giving an alarm
about a candidate signal but doesn't
give any noise because why would anyone
not be looking at a monitor in a place
like this know how to keep your audience
guessing 101 I have three characters
talking once all of whom are spewing
techno babble right now brilliant
ha ha ha ha ha Netscape ha ha ha
also live video this good on Netscape or
any browser this early in the Internet's
lifespan your having sent this
announcement all over the world may well
constitute a breach of national security
typical America aliens from outer space
say hello we think we own that can you
clean it up anyone I'm working on it ah
zoom in enhance cliche intelligent alien
life sends earth back some instructions
with the image of Hitler because
something needs to give James Woods a
reason to be even more of a dick in this
movie 20 million people died defeating
that son of a bitch and he's our first
ambassador to outer space she says it's
like any human had control over what the
aliens want also yeah he's kind of the
defining human of the century just by
being a hundred percent evil hey have
you considered the aliens might hate us
because of our history because it seems
totally plausible to me especially now
claire shipman is at the white house no
she isn't in fact I'm not even sure this
reporter is real and whoever's operating
the camera is fired and that he won't be
taking any questions from the press also
is she filming this as he's walking up
here that's unprecedented access Robert
Zemeckis did this thing with his effects
team in Forrest Gump
putting the fictional characters in real
footage and it now feels like a kid who
can't stop playing with a new toy also a
movie will go on to be 95 percent
absolute fiction while relying on CGI
weirdness like this to establish some
semblance of reality
if this discovery is confirmed why is
the American president giving a speech
about a huge scientific finding before
it's confirmed
and then Zemeckis performs this kind of
neat trick where everybody's in sync
with what we see on the TV but that is
so not Bill Clinton in the background
I'm turning you over to the leader of
the scientific team that made this
remarkable
discovery dr. David drumlin person who
rightfully thinks the other person is
talking about him or her and starts
walking toward the stage is given a
swift rebuttal because life is cliche
also how did Jodie Foster's character
ever think she was supposed to speak to
the point she had notecards
given that her boss is ultimately the
speaker this is a great movie moment to
show how the little chief feels in
general but makes no sense whatsoever
in 1936 a very faint television signal
transmitted the opening ceremonies of
the Olympic Games and what these aliens
did was they saw this and immediately
said yes these people need to know how
to create a machine that will tackle the
complexity of the einstein-rosen bridge
send it back to them now watching for
live news broadcasts at once on with the
sound on makes no sense at all goddamnit
at least mute two or three to you so you
can hear one of them so it turns out
there's life on other planets boy this
is really gonna change the Miss Universe
contest don't you say fast in the
contact us Wow Jake Busey is even more
terrifying than the real Gary Busey
barely Ellie's computer back at the
hotel was on at all times and gives her
a screen saver notification she's got
new email is this an email I admit I
lived in 1997 it's tough to confess the
truth sometimes I just don't remember
emails being this way ever you should
feel fortunate he hardly lands by anyone
there's no way a real Butler employed by
a gazillionaire would ever say this in
real life unless the audience needed to
know it hadn't stops this movie dead
cold by showing a long biographical
video of Ellie which feels in some tiny
gaps as to how smart she is but does not
explain how she kept living in that
house at 9 years old without working
five illegal jobs also where in the sky
get those home movies of Ellie the very
least this guy needs to be investigated
for having his employees raid the
Arroway estate just to make an Ellie fan
video in secret this guy spends way too
many minutes telling Ellie about herself
so he can feel on nishan I guess I
should thank you for having bailed me
out all that time I know the bet when I
see one what because she's smart because
she's obsessed and the actual finding of
intelligent life was a miracle honestly
this was not a good bet that's
results-oriented thinking it's like that
guy at the poker table who's like I know
I'm beat but I call your all-in bet
because there's that one card and the
deck that can save me and then he hits
it and turns and says I 100% made the
correct decision
Lavagirl this movie has the misfortune
of coming well after both Total Recall
in Jurassic Park and thus earns a sin
for this terribly unoriginal line of
dialogue there's no reason to believe
that their intentions are hostile as
James Woods asshole character will no
doubt point out there's also no reason
to believe their intentions are benign
so I guess send this for inconsistency
and
James was being good at cinemasins which
we hate admitting to be honest why is
this asshole allowed in the meeting and
late no less and this asshole too since
he won't even show back up in this movie
after the scene and he's super close
because Palmer is already here should
have taken on the form of a burning bush
or a big booming voice from the sky but
a voice from the sky is exactly what you
found dr. Arroway I wouldn't blame Elly
for killing every man in this movie by
the time it's over like somewhere it
takes this amazing left turn where Elias
suddenly has those Carrie powers and
she's trapping all those mothers in a
gymnasium setting it on fire and singing
Beyonce sorry on the way out she'd know
that song because of time traveling in
the late 90s this was some impressive
ass CGI today however it's in worthy so
there lead it to the religious to loudly
protest an event about a proven alien
space signal movie inspires Westboro
Baptist Church these religious hecklers
are talking only about her scientific
findings and not even one makes a crack
about how long she sat a chair to have
her hair done like this what if science
simply revealed that he never existed in
the first place
Ellie obviously has no concept of
religion because she asks this question
of a religious person without a trace of
comedy or irony no Occam's razor it's a
basic scientific principle all things
being equal the simplest explanation
can't be the right one come on Ellie I
watched a very detailed video of home
movies created by John Hurt that
explains how smart you are this is a
simplistic understanding of Occam's
razor to the point it's not even true
Occam's razor is a way of reducing the
number of hypotheses and a given problem
not the scientific equivalent of the
butler did it your dad did you love him
yes
much proven Ellie says she'd need proof
to believe in God then he asked her to
prove she loved her dead father as
though the two were in any way related
proof of God and proof of loving one's
dad assuming either as possible or two
completely different concepts dude he
decided a science advisor he wants to be
the one to go tom skerritt totally just
picket fenced his loyal underling Ellie
also a yr drumlin and Ellie even being
considered for this travel into space
this is like that miles teller a
Fantastic Four problem we're the guys
who made the Machine wanted to be the
astronauts too well guess what you don't
have the training to be an astronaut
sending you up there makes about as much
sense as sending the actress Jodie
Foster cost of the project is spiraling
to more than a third of a trillion
dollars who sis numbers like this a
third of a trillion dollars we verified
this reporter isn't an alien fully
one-third of the candidates are American
many international observers are asking
why while simultaneously ignoring the
fact that American scientists are the
ones who detected and deciphered the
alien message in the first place
apparently u.s.a u.s.a different nations
are being compensated in different ways
for example i understand the news cut
her off and that's the point but i can't
believe a professional news broadcast
edited it like this to the point of
almost saying
whew angela bassett some of that
criticism from scientist one Nobel Prize
winner recently noted his words you
don't need to know the name of said
Nobel Prize winner and also he says
women should stay in the kitchen I don't
know where that came from but he won the
Nobel so forget I told my dad that I
didn't want him to go daddy don't go
extremely stage child actor is ruined a
movie scene about a candidate dropping
out of the alien encounter discussion
and you travel to Vega at even close to
the speed of light when you come back if
you come back you'll only be four years
older but over fifty years would have
passed here on earth yeah it's exactly
what happened in interstellar what
didn't see that movie oh it's great
great performances from Anne Hathaway
Matt Damon Jessica Chastain Casey
Affleck Michael Caine scores of others
I'm probably missing and Matthew
McConaughey and Jodie Foster two great
actors somehow inadvertently create the
most Awkward kiss in film history and
walked out me did only one question to
ask of them what would it be how did you
do it I would ask them something super
vague like how did you do it and that
would be the one question and that's how
I started the War of the Worlds
how did you evolve how did you survive
this technological adolescence without
destroying yourself one question Ellie
the man said one question do you believe
in God Jesus Christ Oh
so this movie suggests the selection of
our first contact astronauts sent to
speak with aliens will be based on the
candidates religiousness and the sin is
for how much that feels like what would
really happen 95 percent of the world's
population believes in a Supreme Being
in one form or another I'd like to see
the data on that or do you just believe
that made-up stat here this is how you
close your hand also movies cheesy I'm
giving you back the gift you gave me
moment is further cheese if I buy said
item being in on the nose King actual
compass and and backstabber mcdu shootin
gets the job over Jodie Foster because
he pandered to the god-fearing
congressman and considering Jodie Foster
ends up actually making the trip that's
a thirty minute waste of time you just
watched in a two-and-a-half-hour movie
I'm giving out wings David drumlin is
supervising the on-site portion of the
test we spoke with him earlier today
hop Jesus this guy's busy he's the main
astronaut on this mission he's also
supervising the spacecraft's
construction and he's giving regular
media interviews hot religious Superman
astronaut is giving a TV interview while
holding a pair of underwear and while
the movie will ignore that I cannot
Hallie
I know you must think this is all very
I'm chair what you poaching my discovery
and stealing all the glory no totally
cool with that
I just want to bone band here back on
ahead we only get one shot at this let's
get it right we only get one shot at
this cliche
not to mention that like many movies
that employ this cliche there is
actually a secret surprise second shot
coming also the NASA control room in
Apollo 13 looked more technologically
advanced than this bullshit how in the
other lovin did this asshole get onto
the launching pad this guy must have
connections but all of his connections
supposed to forgotten he looks like Jake
Busey and therefore probably is a
villain Jake Busey waited until he was
noticed before committing this act of
terror relax no one was killed during
this blast except those who had been
previously marked by the screenwriter I
hated that devious rat bastard but I'm
still shocked he died so suddenly face
Bill Clinton has more screen time in
this movie than he does in his own
impeachment hearing video course it's
raining now because the world knows that
everything is sad yep the Japanese made
a completely separate machine costing
billions of dollars likely requiring
hundreds of workers totally in secret
from any government somehow despite the
fact that everyone's using satellites on
everyone they come in to call this
machina ex machina they still want an
American to go doctor want to take a
ride oh oh
that want to take a ride is so perfectly
insane in this delivery I'm taking ass
it off Digital microchip good for
thousands of hours of recording
recording what text audio no way in hell
you mean video right right
this guy the reason I didn't vote you to
go le was because I don't want to lose
you thanks Captain Obvious not only are
you delivering information everyone
already knew but you're doing so at the
expense of this movie ending here this
is how you close your hand so they just
decided to run this second machine with
no test whatsoever this time right
as long as Jake Busey is dead this is
safe I guess for a super long movie all
this taking way to super long copy that
35% mechanical we're good how do you
know though this is alien technology
constructed by non aliens and now
monitored by non aliens so how can any
call sign in this NASA will respond
we're good like they have any clue
what's going on yep they're launching
her into space in a craft with unknown
technology without a space helmet Steve
he could have tremendous EMI levels
around the sheet Dave we're approaching
our abort limits this movie space bosses
call each other by their first name
instead of saying like flight or launch
or other NASA actually uses for missions
I hear her I hear her barely but she's
there okay go says she's okay to go I'm
removing another sin because even though
this is taking 8 minutes I'm totally
riveted the music by Alan Silvestri the
suspense the beca's creates it's awesome
this is just a compass but can I just
send this for being Matthew McConaughey
again hey shit what were they gonna
allow the poet to bring his pencil and
notepad on this mission so he could
write some easily forgettable about
something as cool as this and also can't
you just be happy you won le drumlins
dead so everybody wins Ellie goes from
her spacecraft to fetal position
free-floating in space to walking on a
beach on some alien planet that even if
she believes all this is real she should
be questioning how it's possible and why
space travel has to include a fetal
position free floating in space portion
how's the green screen room Ellie I
don't care what happens
Ellie you should have some sort of
skepticism that she was sent anywhere
after this because this looks fake it
did they shoot this movie in
chronological order because they ran out
of a fixed budget for this dad alien and
the movie suffers for it and thus here's
the part that loses everybody we spent
two hours trying to get Ellie into space
we want to see something awesome she
runs into her father or rather an alien
playing Halloween and dressed up as
David Morse
I think everyone would have been happy
with a bunch of aliens in a room full of
confetti and a big congratulations Ellie
sign strung up on a wall but we got her
dad that's the alien we thought this
might make things easier for you can why
also even though we know you as a person
of science and you'd probably like to
see how things really are we decided to
make things easier for you and not to
allow your camera to record you
detected us we were just listening we
have like a hundred and fifty five
Ellie's here who spent fifteen years
listening to the universe and just
before funding fell through we were
saved by that Hitler message we didn't
build it we don't know who did the main
purpose of bringing you here is to raise
even more questions so forgive you're
capable of such beautiful dreams and
such horrible nightmares Jesus we like
entered a whole different quality a
picture here didn't the people need to
see what I've seen they need to see this
is the way it's been done for billions
of years
how frustrating no wonder the universe
is terrible how long was I God the IPV
dropped straight through the machine you
didn't go anywhere yep aliens spent all
that time designing a ship for humans
and sending instructions for them to
contact the aliens only to Kelly over
and make all of earth doubt the
existence of aliens do I have that right
because if so galleons man although this
movie's America for never even
considering that alien space travel
technology might actually also
manipulate time
it's like Einstein never existed in this
movies universe or something the entire
country legit makes her feel crazy for
suggesting she might actually have gone
somewhere and come back faster than
humans could detect and that's fucking
nuts
are you really gonna sit there and tell
us we should just take this all on faith
way to go world you Ellie this whole
movie finally gave her a chance to do
something awesome then shit on her again
even at the point that she's forced to
defend her beliefs like a religious
person would way to turn it around on
such a vile person Bravo
thankfully for Ellie's frame of mind
shortly before embarking on a space
journey no one believes happened she
fell in love with a man of faith who can
now understand and comfort her better
whenever you testify before Congress
they make you leave by the front door in
case thousands of people are out there
protesting or supporting it that's
totally how it works and what happens
snque is told is DP I want every
single crowd shot in this scene to
prominently feature the color blue when
asked why he replied where is my latte
how do you believe as a person faith
apparently tens of thousands of people
decided to shut up so that Palmer could
answer this reporter's question the fact
that it recorded static ISM what
interest me what interests me is that it
recorded approximately 18 hours of it
how in the ever-living it's not
discovered and disclosed during the
hearings this is actually the most
preposterous thing this movie has
suggested what this over long think
piece sci-fi film definitely needed to
make it perfect was an 18 months later
flash-forward kappa because the story
wasn't already wrapped up nicely it was
and the 18 months after Ellie's hearing
are in no way uninteresting
they are see over there we're building
45 brand new dishes but we'll never
build another one of those machines
again even after the hard proof that I
went somewhere for 18 hours no funding
necessary for that that's home that's us
on it everyone you love everyone you
know you Mars so what it's my life don't
ever tell me what I can't do and Jimmy
two times who got that nickname because
he said everything twice like animal
protection minimal protection I hope to
see my friend that shake his hand
I hope the Pacific is as blue as it has
been in my dreams I hope the witness
will address this court as judge or your
honor I'm quite certain I've earned it
the universe is a pretty big place you
just won't believe how vastly hugely
mind-boggling Liebig it is I mean you
may think it's a long way down the
street to the chemist but that's just
peanuts to space listen and so on